SPEAKER: One of the first
and most important steps
to optimizing your costs is
being able to understand them.
Today, we'll talk about
a few different ways
to understand your Google
Kubernetes Engine costs,
and go over a few
best practices.
Let's go beyond your GKE bill.
If you haven't watched
the last video,
I definitely recommend taking
the time to check it out,
since we talked a bit
about teams and culture.
These concepts are super
important for being
able to get a solid
understanding of your costs.
I'll start by giving an
overview of some ways
that you can understand more
about your GKE infrastructure
and applications.
Then I'll go over how
to turn these details
into actionable steps,
and then finish up
with some
cost-optimizing policies.
Your organization might have
a platform and infrastructure
team that manages
the clusters, which
can be completely separate
from the dev team that actually
write the applications.
When every team understands
the cost implications
for the decisions they make,
like how many resources an app
actually needs, they
can all work together
to get things optimized.
So where do you start?
Well, that's probably going to
be the monitoring dashboard.
When using GKE, the
cluster's Info page
shows a lot of details.
But we're looking for some
details about our metrics,
so let's head over to
the Monitoring page.
This is part of Cloud
Operations, which
has a bunch of helpful
functionality for monitoring,
logging, and alerting.
If it's your first time
using Cloud Operations,
you'll have a workspace created
for you or you can create one
manually.
Either way, as long as
your cluster was set up
with Cloud Operations for GKE,
a dashboard will automatically
be created, named "GKE."
This dashboard
gives us the ability
to see our Kubernetes
information
over a time series, grouped
by cluster, node, pod,
and container.
We're on the Infrastructure
tab, which is a perfect view
to get more details on the
CPU and memory utilization,
and if there are any
issues with the nodes.
The Services tab gives
the same information,
but from a service-centric
point of view--
useful when there's
a service disruption.
There's also a workload tab that
gives you an app-centric view.
This view is a helpful way to
get an idea of what's going on,
but we can also get more detail
by using the Metrics Explorer.
Here, we can create
custom charts with options
to filter, group, and aggregate.
For instance, we
can create a chart
that would let us see the
CPU usage time by container.
You can even create
a custom dashboard
that shows more custom charts.
If you use Cloud Logging and
Cloud Monitoring to provide
observability into your
apps and infrastructure,
you're only paying
for what you use.
However, the more that they log
and the longer you keep those
logs, the more that
you'll pay for them.
Plus, the more external and
custom metrics you have,
the more you'll pay
for those, as well.
There's a link in
the description that
gives a great overview and lots
of tips on cost optimization,
specifically for
logs and monitoring.
Also, we talked about
multi-tenant clusters before.
And if you're using
those, you probably
want to make sure that
you're sending the logs back
to the tenants for their usage.
The cost savings tip here
is to use exclusion rules
so that you can filter out
the logs you don't care about
before you get charged for them.
There's another link
in the description
that goes over setting that up.
OK, so we've seen the
built-in dashboards,
but that might not
even be enough.
If you want to get
even more granular,
you can enable GKE
Usage Monitoring
to set up automatic
collection of metrics,
and then export
then the BigQuery.
Once in BigQuery, you'll be able
to see specific usage of CPUs,
GPUs, TPUs, memory, storage,
and even network egress.
These details can
be used to compare
actual usage versus
allocated resources,
and then you can
figure out where
you might be over-allocated.
Following the best practice
of splitting teams or apps
by namespace also
gives you the ability
to easily see the resource
usage and cost for each one.
Labels can also be
used for filtering.
The most important thing
is to consider the culture
suggestions from
the last episode,
and help make teams aware--
and even accountable-- for
the costs that they incur.
Remember, high cost
doesn't automatically
mean that something
is wrong, but you
don't want to pay for things
that you're not using.
Now that we've gone over
the monitoring side,
let's take a look at
some ways to take action
on those insights.
With the ability to see exactly
how resources are being used,
you may also want to use
Kubernetes Resource Quotas.
Resource Quotas let you
cap the amount of resources
that a namespace can use,
which is another great reason
to use multi-tenant clusters
to split up by namespaces.
This can help you
keeping any tenant
from consuming too many
resources, which might then
trigger auto-scaling.
Limit ranges are another way to
enforce resource limitations,
but they're actually at
a pod and cluster level.
The real value comes from
understanding detailed metrics
and using those to set
appropriate quotas.
If you're using a
version of Kubernetes
that supports a
metrics server, there's
some good things to know.
The metric server helps
collect and then expose metrics
to the Kubernetes metrics API.
When an application is
using a lot of resources,
the metrics server can
be used to figure out
when you should auto-scale.
That's great, but
the metrics server
is still a deployment itself,
which means that it actually
needs to be running somewhere.
As a cluster gets more
nodes and deployments,
the metric server needs
to grow along with it.
However, when it's time for
the metric server to grow,
it has to be restarted.
If your cluster is
changing quickly,
this could mean a lot of
restarts, which could then
cause a small delay
in auto-scalers,
and even small delays
in auto-scaling
can add up to big impact.
So the best practice
here is to make sure you
work with your metric server.
Newer versions of GKE
support a resize delay
to help keep your metric server
from restarting as often,
make sure that your version
supports the scale-down delay
to avoid too many restarts,
and ensure that you monitor
the metric server
as a top priority
to avoid potential
auto-scaling issues.
Another way to avoid
potential issues
is to make sure that
any configuration
changes are reviewed
before they get deployed.
So if a team unexpectedly
updates a config
with 1,000 replicas,
you can deal with it
before it spikes your costs.
The Anthos Policy
Controller is one way
to help automate this
by checking, auditing,
and enforcing those policies
that you've created.
These policies can help you
control security, regulations,
and custom business
logic that might
affect your costs or your
application stability.
In addition to this, you
can use a tool like KPT
to build this logic into
your CI/CD pipeline,
so you're automatically
validating any configurations
through the development cycle.
It's also a good idea to keep
your eyes on the Recommendation
Hub.
All kinds of recommendations
come up here,
from security to cost.
These are based on
your usage, so there
are specific
suggestions for how you
might be able to make
changes and might
be able to save money.
For example, based on
your usage patterns,
you could optimize
your compute costs
by purchasing
long-term commitments.
We'll talk about that
more in the next video.
The key here is
having visibility
into what resources your
deployments, namespaces, apps,
whatever are actually
using, and understanding how
you can optimize around that.
On the next video,
we'll talk more
about optimizing your costs
based on the machines that
actually run the applications.
Remember to check out the
link in the description
for the full guide on
GKE cost optimization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]